[Music]
on this Wednesday night what goes up is
still going up the Bank of Canada hikes
its Trend setting interest rate again
this time to its highest level in 22
years if we don't do enough now we'll
likely have to do even more later the
questions about whether this is the
wisest strategy for Canadians
supporting Ukraine the g7's new
commitments and what Canada is pledging
Scandal rocks the BBC the allegations
taking down one of Britain's biggest
journalists and a road map to 37
trillion human cells we think this
process will never really end the
mission to build the world's largest
reference book
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us
Canada's Central Bank has raised its
Benchmark interest rate once again
increasing borrowing costs for Canadians
and signaling more financial pain ahead
for those carrying a lot of debt after
hitting a pause in January the Central
Bank resumed its historic rate hiking
last month and again today with a 25
basis point hike this is the 10th
increase to Canada's key lending rate
since March of last year pushing it to
five percent the last time it was this
high was in April of 2001.
higher interest rates are needed to slow
the growth of demand in the economy and
relieve price pressures we continue to
expect economic growth to moderate and
inflation to ease but this will take
longer than we forecast in January and
April
this rate hike was highly anticipated
though the economy is performing better
than most forecasters had predicted and
there are questions about the central
bank's approach and whether it's the
right one Mackenzie gray has our top
story tonight
we are certainly trying he's the bearer
of bad news yet again Tiff Macklin
raising rates for the 10th time in 16
months you know we know that if we don't
do enough now uh we'll likely have to do
even more later the Bank of Canada
increasing their key interest rate to 5
blaming inflation that's stubbornly high
gone to the days of 8.1 percent from
last summer but the bank's two percent
Target is still far off our own forecast
has inflation hovering around three
percent for the next year and then
coming down gradually the two percent
Target in the middle of 2025. my
amortization went up by about nine years
the rising rates hitting zahab shake
hard he's needing to cut back on his
spending to make increased payments on
his variable rate mortgage are like over
six percent right now and due to that
interested increase I have like about
approximately 600 increase in my monthly
mortgage payments those higher monthly
payments caused by the rate hike run up
are now one of the biggest drivers of
inflation the current 3.4 percent
inflation rate drops to 2.5 percent
right in the bank's Target when the
impact of mortgage interest costs is
taken out leading some economists to
believe the latest hike wasn't needed
the bank's own research tells us it
takes 18 to 24 months
for the full impact of interest rate
changes to impact the economy which
means we're only just starting to see
the impact of their first rate hikes
even as those effects are felt the bank
still believes that Canadian house
prices will continue to increase we've
had very strong immigration uh and some
very foreign workers arriving in the
country so uh you know all those
households need somewhere to live there
is some good news the bank is still
predicting a so-called soft Landing
where inflation gets to two percent with
no recession but as for further hikes
Donna tip Macklin says the bank is
willing to send rates higher if needed
okay Mackenzie gray will keep watching
thanks a quick note on inflation in the
United States it has fallen to the
lowest it's been in two years the U.S
labor department puts the annual
inflation rate for June at 3 percent
down from four percent in May and the
lowest it's been in the U.S since March
of 2021. the U.S federal reserve chose
not to raise its Benchmark interest rate
last month holding it steady in a range
of 5 to 5.2 percent
[Music]
with me from Ottawa is Armenian
Economist and Atkinson fellow on the
future of workers I mean the intent of
the Bank of Canada raising the key
interest rate is to cool inflation and
we've had multiple increases over the
past year inflation has shown signs of
cooling so why raise rates do you see
the wisdom in doing that
I personally don't see the wisdom in
doing that and there's a growing
consensus amongst mainstream economists
both former Chief economists at central
banks like the bank of England and
people on Wall Street saying exactly the
same thing that I'm just about to say to
you which is getting from three to two
percent seems like an awful lot of pain
for very little gain and will have
long-term scarring impacts on both
individuals at economic potential for
the economy so do we really need to get
to two percent quite as quickly if this
is just a matter of months the bank
would say it's an insurance policy if we
focus on two percent and get there as
fast as we can any upside unpleasant
surprises will prevent us from going
back into an era where we have to crank
up rates again so you know it's in the
eye of the beholder whether that's a
good idea or a bad idea what is the
potential long-term impact on Canadians
especially people who have you know
variable rate mortgages and lines of
credit
well we are seeing this commercial Banks
actually softening the blow for some
people by extending amortization to 60
70 80 years not in perpetuity but for uh
for a little while so that people can
adjust to the rate increases so that's
another thing that a central bank can do
is to extend its time Horizon so the
ding for Rising rates might not be quite
as harsh as we might have otherwise
expected but do expect to see more
people unable to hang on and we'll try
and turn to sell particularly condos in
this market and that should normally
reduce the price of condos except the
price of everything has gone up so we
don't know what kind of price adjustment
will happen in the market the first six
months of 2023 price housing prices did
fall but now they're up again so that's
partly because we've poured in a lot of
people into the economy more than a
million people have come into Canada in
the last year and that means there's
more demand for housing just as you know
households are puzzles that do have
extra properties have pulled them off of
rental markets into short-term rental
markets to make more money to cover the
cost so we're actually bleeding more
affordable rental housing out of the
market than we're building and that's a
real problem that's cranking up rental
rates and army let me ask about the big
Banks we know they're very profitable
they hike their Prime rates to 7.2
percent today why is that automatic do
they have to do that and raise their
mortgage rates every time the Bank of
Canada raises its rate
that is the way the system is supposed
to function the Central Bank raises its
overnight lending rate for the banks
that borrow from one another overnight
to settle their accounts and those Banks
just push through those costs to the
whole Cascade of other borrowing costs
and that's exactly why when a central
bank raises its rates it's designed to
make borrowing more expensive for
everybody it starts with the banks
themselves and Cascades through but you
are absolutely right the banks have
never been more profitable so it's a bit
difficult to swallow all right Economist
Armenian thank you
my pleasure
there is a development today on the BC
Port strike that's gone on for 12 days
Canada's labor Minister has stepped in
asking a federal mediator to give the
union and the employer a recommendation
of a settlement both sides who are
blaming each other for not reaching a
deal have until tomorrow morning to
respond as Nita Garcia reports the
economic impact of this strike is
growing by the hour
the 12th day of the BC Port strike began
like every other for these workers with
more picketing but this time their Union
and their employer have a settlement
offer in front of them with a deadline
to accept or reject clearly a sincere
effort by the minister to have the
settled between the parties rather than
through legislation on Tuesday labor
Minister Sheamus O'Regan directed The
mediators to draft terms for a
settlement the minister said as a result
of the hard work by the parties at the
bargaining table there is a good deal
Within Reach with 24 hours to respond
the two sides were given the settlement
terms around 10 30 Wednesday morning the
same time business groups held this news
conference in Vancouver demanding an end
to the port shutdown we are calling on
the
government and
the Hardees to be ready to pass
to Work legislation if mediation is
unsuccessful we are seeing a Slowdown in
our operations and a shutdown starting
this week
this goes on for a few more weeks this
is going to cost us 150 to 200 000 in
sales small businesses like this
Beverage Company in Abbotsford BC with
cargo stuck at the Port also called for
more action to get the goods flowing
again we can't fill our orders to
you know major retailers that you shop
at every day so it affects the 12 people
that work here and we're a small family
business it's it's a huge deal for us
Port workers in the U.S refuse to unload
canadian-bound Cargo in solidarity with
their Canadian counterparts about 7 500
BC port workers walked off the job on
July 1st key issues include automation
cost of living and outside Contracting
both sides blaming each other for
failing to reach a deal nitu karcha
Global News Vancouver
the high stakes NATO Summit wrapped up
in Lithuania today with the war in
Ukraine front and center Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski was there
too his country isn't part of the
alliance but he is pushing hard for
membership zelenski did not get what he
came for but he did meet with top
leaders including the American President
Joe Biden in a tweets zelenski said he
had a very good powerful meeting and it
was at least twice as long as planned
and it was as meaningful as it needed to
be there was progress and as David Aiken
reports from Vilnius leaders including
prime minister Justin Trudeau say
they're prepared to offer Ukraine
long-term security guarantees
the first meeting Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski had as he arrived at
the NATO Summit was a one-on-one meeting
with prime minister Justin Trudeau all
awesome all often and that's really
Canadians helped Ukraine and helped from
the very beginning of full scale War we
really encountered you people and we are
the same and we you know that we fight
for the same values Canada may not have
all the wealth or weapons that Ukraine
wants but because of Canada's special
relationship with Ukraine Trudeau can be
Ukraine's Advocate and Ally where
Ukraine has no official voice at NATO at
the G7 the G20 and so on and then
Trudeau can provide zielinski with
counsel and advice there is not much
debate at home about standing with
Ukraine
with everything necessary for as long as
necessary
zielinski came to Vilnius hoping for
Ukraine's quick entry into NATO he did
not get that but he did get some weapons
packages he wanted missiles from France
air defense systems from Germany and
more Munitions from the U.S he also got
a commitment from G7 leaders for
long-term security guarantees Ukrainian
delegation is bringing home significant
security victory for the Ukraine for our
country for our people for our children
the details of those security guarantees
are still to be worked out but the G7
believes the commitment sends a message
to the Kremlin I think it's a powerful
statement a powerful statement of our
commitment to Ukraine as it defends its
freedom today and as it rebuilds the
future Vladimir Putin wants to wait out
and grind down the alliance grind down
ukrainians well he's not going to be
able to because we will be there for as
long as it takes and that's what these
security assurances are all about Canada
also announced some new programs for
Ukraine Canadians will train Ukrainian
air crew to maintain and operate F-16
fighter jets and Canadians will host and
train Ukrainian officer cadets at Royal
Military College Saint Jean in Quebec
Donna okay David Aiken and Vilnius
Lithuania tonight thanks people in two
flood ravaged regions are surveying the
destruction tonight how the forecast in
Quebec is looking better than what's in
store for the U.S state of Vermont
that's coming up
foreign
you can see from these satellite
pictures what parts of Vermont and New
York look like before and after the
intense flooding this week Heavy Rain
slammed the Northeastern United States
and while the water is starting to
recede the crisis is not over more rain
is forecast later this week Jackson
prosco reports on the cleanup and how
people are bracing for what's still to
come
a thick layer of mud coats everything
careful after flood water surged into
stores and homes in Vermont's Capital
the water must have just upended all of
this
the disaster inundated Montpelier
leaving behind tens of millions of
dollars in damage the cleanup is Major
so there's a lot of it's traumatizing to
some degree people who survived the
rushing waters are shaken I'm just
realizing that you had water up to here
it was absolutely insane and it's really
unlike any other event I've ever lived
through
though much of the water has receded the
risk is far from over the ground is
saturated the rivers still swollen and
there's more heavy rain in the forecast
we have to continue to be vigilant and
mindful that more flooding is a very
real possibility
this once in a generation flood offers a
stark warning about a changing climate
where warmer more humid weather fuels
flash flood events areas that once seem
safe may no longer be I think everybody
needs to sort of pay attention to their
environments and their landscape as we
learn about these additional changes
that are going on in the atmosphere
itself because they all need to sort of
come together it's the community that's
coming together in the flood zone as
vermonters survey the damage it's just
heartbreaking to see it it's going to
take so long to get back to where it was
as the flood waters recede for now
they've Left Behind worry about what the
future may bring
Jackson prosco Global News
floodwaters have receded enough in parts
of Southern Quebec now for many people
to return home the mayor of Saint
Brigitte de Laval says River levels have
stabilized there and everyone should be
home by tomorrow days of torrential rain
flooded properties and damaged roads
about 250 homes were evacuated earlier
this week the province says financial
aid will be available for those affected
in British Columbia a fiery crash has
closed the trans-canada highway in both
directions just west of Revelstoke
multiple First Responders were called to
the scene this afternoon BC emergency
Health Services say paramedics cared for
five patients at the scene and took
three to the hospital police at the
scene tell Global News two people have
died there's no detour around the crash
and no estimated time for the highway to
reopen
still I had the allegations surrounding
one of the BBC's best-known journalists
[Music]
the rcmp's major crimes unit is
investigating at least 70 cases of
alleged sexual assault at a provincial a
run Youth Detention Facility in Nova
Scotia RCMP say the suspected assaults
happened at the facility in Waterville
between 1988 and 2017 and that the
majority of survivors are male who were
between the ages of 12 and 18 at the
time investigators have spoken to 70
people as part of operation headwind
they believe more than 200 may be
involved a conventional confidential
hotline has been set up to encourage
people to come forward with any
information related to the investigation
in the UK a prominent news anchor at the
BBC has been named as the person at the
center of a tabloid newspaper story
about allegations of payments for
sexually explicit images
Buckingham Palace has announced the
death of her majesty Queen Elizabeth II
from announcing the death of the queen
to elections and anchoring the flagship
newscast 61-year-old Hugh Edwards has
been a big part of every story for the
BBC for decades last week the Sun
newspaper claimed a BBC anchor had paid
a teenager 35 000 pounds for explicit
photographs it didn't name Edwards but
today his wife did issuing a statement
saying Hugh is suffering from serious
mental health issues he has been treated
for severe depression in recent years
she says and is now receiving inpatient
hospital care the BBC had suspended
Edwards and referred the matter to the
police who have since concluded there
was no evidence of a criminal offense
and the Sun newspaper now insists it
never meant to imply anything illegal
took place and says it has no plans to
publish further allegations
Czech born novelist and SAS Milan
kundero one of the biggest names in
European literature has died at the age
of 94. kundera became an international
sensation with his 1984 novel The
unbearable lightness of being he
investigated themes of Exile memory and
love and intertwined tragic tales with
satirical portrayals of Life under
communist depression kundera became a
leading intellectual dissident opposing
the Communist Party of Czechoslovakia
and eventually fleeing for France in
1975 he was stripped of his Czech
citizenship and his books were banned
there until a Velvet Revolution of 1989
he spent much of his later life in
seclusion
ambitious Atlas next the efforts to
create an unprecedented reference book
of the human body
[Music]
the Canadian food inspection agency
tells Global News it will recall a
highly caffeinated energy drink promoted
by popular YouTube Stars Prime energy
contains 200 milligrams of caffeine per
can exceeding Health Canada's allowable
limit of 180 milligrams the agency says
it is aware the beverage is being sold
in some Canadian stores without approval
and is actively working to address the
issue
hundreds of scientists from around the
world have come together in Toronto to
work on an ambitious goal mapping every
cell in the human body they want to
create the biggest reference book ever
and make it accessible to health experts
everywhere Catherine Ward explains why
they're doing it and what difference it
could make
everyone's coming together kind of thick
to to figure out how to put it all
together the liver the heart the
pancreas every cell is up for discussion
as more than 3 000 people from around
the world work to create the largest
reference book on the planet the human
body has over 37 trillion cells on
average and we don't know a lot about
most what most of these cells do and so
we're mapping those to find out where
they all are and discover new ones as
well it's called the human cell Atlas a
project that started in 2016. it's
thought that even very rare populations
of cells can drive disease Gary Bader
and Sony mcparland are part of the
Canadian team helping to map the liver
by figuring out where all these cells
live in the human body scientists are
hopeful this will help with more
targeted treatments it's already proving
its worth we've learned that there's
multiple populations in the liver that
can either promote regeneration so
tissue repair or they can promote things
like transplant rejection it raises a
possibility that you could reprogram a
liver to be less likely to reject
Bader says the atlas helped with another
breakthrough a new type of cell
discovered in the lung it carries the
gene for Cystic Fibrosis we can now know
where cystic fibrosis is acting in the
lung and we can start understanding how
it breaks the lung in in that genetic
disease experts say this is a book that
will be written for many years to come
we think this process will never really
end it will always be iterative will
always be kind of working more towards
really understanding health and then
disease Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada takes you well beyond our
country to the birth of stars this
breathtaking photo from the James Webb
Space Telescope shows dozens of stars at
the moment of birth NASA says all of
them are similar to the Sun's mass or
smaller the image was released to Mark
the first anniversary of the James Webb
Space Telescope thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you